bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous
sur lcp public sénat pour parlement
hebdo notre rendez vous politique et
parlementaire les moments forts de
l'actualité de la semaine présenté avec
michaël szames est rouge en quatre
heures bonjour michael et c'est parti
pour le dialogue social les députés
examinent le texte en procédure
d'urgence la réforme portée par françois
rebsamen suscite des réserves et les
critiques le ministre sera t'il passer
son texte en forme c'est l'une des
questions de la semaine les socialistes
en ordre de marche pour leur congrès qui
se tiendra dans quelques jours à
poitiers la fraude se calme jean
christophe cambadélis est confirmée à la
tête du parti prochaine échéance les
élections régionales et puis l'hommage
de la nation aux résistants deux hommes
deux femmes qui ont fait l'histoire
entre au panthéon hommage solennel du
chef de l'état et des assemblées pour le
devoir de mémoire et pour commenter
toute cette actualité notre invité cette
semaine que non karine berger bonjour
montchamp députée socialiste des
hautes-alpes spécialiste des questions
économiques évidemment beaucoup abordé
ce sujet cette semaine vous avez été à
la tête de la motion des dites d qui est
arrivé troisième la semaine dernière
lors des élections aux serres du parti
socialiste avec un peu moins de 10% des
voix on va en parler largement aussi
dans cette émission mais il ya une
tradition c'est que les parlementaires
dresse votre portrait et puis on en
parle juste après vous les écoutez
à karine berger bon bien bien connu
maîtresse des décomptes et des budgets
est quelqu'un qui me paraît décidée
ayant du caractère en effet la prouver
du reste des compétences
rafale et qui gagnerait peut-être à
mettre un petit peu un petit peu de
d'arrondi dans les angles peut-être que
ça lui permettrait de mieux faire passer
ses messages je pense que c'est une
députée très compétente
une vraie militante politique qui a des
convictions
qui les défend après j'ai pas toujours
fait les mêmes choix qu'elle est une
voie qui apporte en tout cas d'autres
éléments de réflexion qui ne sont pas
toujours pris en compte dans les débats
actuels est effectivement qui ouvre je
pense certaines pistes qui sont et qui
mérite d'être explorée elle a aussi
l'avantagé je pense de faire le plus
lien peut-être entre des voix qui serait
on va dire sacs des frondeurs et puis
cette d'un gouvernement qui est parfois
fermé à la discussion peut sentiment que
j'ai parfois c'est qu'elle est un
peut-être un petit peu décalé mais aussi
déconnectée des réalités économiques
financières à la fois de l'état et et
des entreprises j'ai peut-être
on a tendance à considérer que ce qui
est important ici c'est le collectif et
le travail collectif donc c'est toujours
gênant quand pour des raisons soit
convictions personnelles soit de
stratégie politique personnelle ce qui
était le cas à l'occasion de ce congrès
on s'écarte du collectif on retiendra
beau somme est conséquente les
collectifs et quelque part un petit peu
original ça vous plaît comme forteresse
j'espère que je suis une députée qui au
milieu des députés qui ont la
quarantaine sont essaye de chaunac ciom
locales et le collectif c'est à dire que
on a une nouvelle génération de droite
comme de gauche qui est apparue sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale en 2012
qui est je crois que c'est intéressant
les règles et les réactions qui
apportent leur expérience
professionnelle ou personnelle avec une
voix qui évidemment quand on a 40 ans et
peut-être un peu plus aigu comme quand
on est un peu plus installé on va dire
un système c'est comme ça que je me vois
essayer de toute évidence un peu comme
ça que les parlementaires veulent du mal
à trouver votre place au pas aux soldes
à écouter un de vos partenaires
peut-être qu'ils ont plus d'expérience
en politique je crois que j'ai ma place
de député et j'essaye de la défendre au
travers à la fois du travail socialiste
et du travail personnel hautes-alpes à
l'assemblée nationale c'est un groupe au
parlement c'est une assemblée de députés
qui doivent apporter chacun leur
expérience et leurs compétences et voilà
etc et c'est cet équilibre là qu'il faut
à tout moment trouver alors karine
bergeron va vous interroger sur les
dossiers de la semaine et notamment
lundi une idée qui refait surface elle
du prélèvement de l'impôt à la source
l'impôt prélevé à la source l'impôt sur
le revenu c'est pour la fin du
quinquennat parole de bruno le roux le
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée prélèvement direct chaque
mois du salaire ou de la pension de la
somme due au trésor public est ce
possible ce serait une révolution
fiscale éléments de réponse avec sophie
normand
c'était une promesse de campagne de
françois hollande mise de côté depuis
est relancé par le parti socialiste à
l'occasion du congrès de poitiers du
parti l'idée d'un prélèvement de l'impôt
à la source
ça doit être le préalable à la grande
réforme fiscale mais la grande réforme
fiscale elle fera l'objet d'une
d'un travail préalable et elle aura lieu
au début d'un voyage à bruno venez vous
l'engagement bruno le roux qu'à la fin
du quinquennat nous avons un prélèvement
à la source qu'il aura commencé à être
mises en place simplement il faut l'état
les mises en place avant 2017 et étalée
sur trois ou quatre ans selon bruno le
roux le temps pour le ministère des
finances d'inventer de nouveaux
logiciels de gestion le temps aussi de
préparer les entreprises car ce sont
elles qui verseront l'impôt sur le
revenu de chaque salarié une fois par
mois avantageux pour les contribuables
qui ne connaîtront plus ce décalage d'un
nom le système présenterait aussi
l'avantagé pour l'état d'avoir une
source de revenu mensuel et non annuel
karine berger votre collègue député du
ps à la commission des finances
dominique lefebvre a dit qu'il
déconseillait fortement le gouvernement
de se lancer sur cette piste est ce que
je vous partage est son avis en tant que
député qui connaissait bien ses
questions à tous ceux qui ont signé le
texte de la motion à jean-charles
dominique lemaire ont fait partie
doivent désormais être favorable à une
mise en oeuvre du prélèvement à la
source puisque c'est la parole des
militants donc nous revenons pas sur ce
débat la question c'est comment on fait
c'est à dire si dante un casse tête qui
sonnait c'est plus qu'un casque est bon
et c'est une difficile difficulté
constitutionnel parce que le prélèvement
à la source et un prélèvement individuel
et que l'impôt sur le revenu c'est un
impôt sur le foyer anne sonnet amelia
c'est un affront familiale comment on
fait se brancher la logique individuelle
avec la logique familiales le conseil
constitutionnel de toute jurisprudence
nous dit il n'est pas possible il n'est
pas possible de prendre directement sur
le salaire de nos dit quoi qu'est-ce que
vous proposerez il ya une seule solution
c'est de prendre la première année de
manière proportionnelle donc non redit
ce nom non progressive un pourcentage un
peu comme la csg et l'année d'après de
refaire le calcul au niveau du foyer
fiscal en intégrant la sandero
c'est la grande difficulté c'est à dire
que si vous demandez aux français
d'avoir un prélèvement proportionnel la
première année techniquement ça signifie
que cette année là ils sont amenés à
payer un peu mais ça pourrait pénaliser
donc je soyez parmi les plus modestes
donc on est vraiment deux sujets qu'on a
un sujet de mise en oeuvre sierre sans
qui évidemment d'augmentation d'impôts
puisque le gouvernement et je crois
qu'il a raison souhaite plutôt baisser
l'impôt sur le revenu au cours des deux
prochaines années donc on à cette
problématique amandine prometic encore
une fois beaucoup plus lourde c'est
qu'il n'existe pas en france de
possibilité de faire un impôt progressif
qui soit non conjugales or par
définition un salaire ce n'est pas
conjugales donc si vous comptez mettre
en place c'est quasiment impossible
c'est pas dit s'agit il simplement
commenté le vibrant pour l'instant je
n'ai pas vu de solution convaincante sur
le sujet dans ce camp bruno le roux
quand le gouvernement quand la personne
était de la motion à disent qu'ils le
veulent avant la fin du quinquennat pour
vous c'est impossible ils ne disent pas
qu'ils veulent à fatiguer quinquennat et
disent qu'ils veulent les gens c'est
louis lelong laurent la fin du
quinquennat donc on peut très bien
encore une fois imaginé une première
étape qui est impropre prélèvement
proportionnel sur les salaires après
cela signifie effectivement qu'il va
falloir probablement bouger dans ce cas
là d'autres impôts pour ça veut dire
double prélèvement oui et bouger aussi
d'autres dispositions fiscales peut-être
finalement entamé une réforme mise à
plat de tout le système fiscal serait
très longue dans notre motion à nous il
ne parlions plus de fusion dans ou de
près les variations parlions de refaire
un nouvel impôt dire qu'on avait dit
explicitement que il fallait oublier le
système actuel refaire un impôt
redistributif
c'était le seul moyen à notre avis pour
arriver à ce qu'on veut faire c'est à
dire simplification plus
deux problématiques de déclaration et en
même temps on repart alors une
progressivité et en distribution est
trop technique vous imaginez que les
promesses tenues par la motion à sont
obligatoires mots doivent absolument
être tenu par le gouvernement alors je
pense que jean christophe cambadelis
aura à coeur de faire en sorte d'en bas
70 % selon les scrutins des militants
ils soient entendus jusqu'au premier
secrétaire je prends le premier ministre
et pour les autres je crois que y
compris pour le premier ministre le
gouvernement c'est très important tout
simplement parce que c'est la
crédibilité de notre formation politique
pour 2017 qui est en jeu on ne peut donc
n'ont pas le choix ils sont obligés de
battre et je pense que la logique
politique fait en sorte que le
gouvernement applique les textes que par
ailleurs il a ils ont voté à titre
habituel mais au delà de l'engagement
individuel c'est la volonté politique
d'être clair et transparent avec les
français en 2017 on en vient au mardi le
texte sur le dialogue social arrive à
l'assemblée nationale
c'est le projet de loi du ministre du
travail françois rebsamen qui est
examiné dans l'hémicycle à l'assemblée
il promet de réformer le dialogue social
il hérite énormément les patrons mais
côté socialiste ne veut pas donc plus
que des heureux regardez la loi sur le
dialogue social arrive dans l'hémicycle
avec 700 amendements déposés l'un des
articles les plus importants la création
d'une représentation du personnel pour
les très petites entreprises soit près
de 5 millions de salariés autre
nouveauté pour les sociétés de moins de
300 personnes
la fusion des ses oeufs des chsct des
délégués du personnel dans une seule
instance pour françois rebsamen ce sont
des avancées sociales sans précédent
le projet de loi que j'ai l'honneur de
vous présenter aujourd'hui s'inscrit
donc dans la continuité
des grandes lois sociales que portent
les gouvernements de gauche depuis plus
de 30 ans ce projet de loi se fonde sur
une conviction qui doit dépasser
largement les clivages partisans les
salariés et les entreprises d'un pays
ont tout à gagner un dialogue social de
meilleure qualité autre nouveauté la
création du compte personnel d'activité
qui regroupera le conte pénibilité le
comte formation et la création de la
prime d'activité dès 2016 c'est à dire
la fusion de la prime pour l'emploi et
du rsa activité censé faciliter le
retour à l'emploi
l'ump dénonce un texte sans ambition et
se moque même de sa forme
je veux quand même signaler monsieur le
ministre à regret la piètre qualité
rédactionnelle du texte que vous nous
proposez le fait qu'il soit encore
truffé de fautes de grammaire et de
français ce texte n'est pas le texte du
grand soir et de la révolution du retour
de l'emploi c'est au moins une occasion
manquée et au pire un texte inutile très
polémique avant même l'examen du texte
la disparition du rapport de situation
comparée un dispositif chiffres et
mesurant l'égalité hommes femmes en
entreprise
face à la fronde des féministes le
gouvernement l'a réintégré par voie
d'amendement autre débat en vue le sujet
du burn out défendu par benoît hamon
mais le gouvernement ne semble pas prêt
à l'intégrer dans ce texte et renvoie un
rapport ultérieur sur le sujet alors
françois rebsamen a laissé planer l'idée
de l'utilisation du 49-3 record lui
aussi ex ordinaire au mois de juillet
pour faire passer ce texte qu'est ce que
vous en pensez je pense que carmat sera
peut être utile à d'autres textes donc
ne l'utilisons pas trop rapidement sur
la loire et de semaine il y as je crois
la volonté dans ce texte de dialogue
social d'antan tout le monde benoît
émond a été entendu sur le burn out je
pense qu'une partie des réactions
féministes sur la problématique de
l'égalité homme femme a été entendue
même si ce n'est pas encore suffisant
bref il y a la volonté de faire en sorte
qu'on revienne à un système normal c'est
à dire que la majorité adopte les textes
de la majorité dont vous êtes confiant
moi je ne souhaite n'est pas
d'utilisation de 40 chansons jours suite
au texte là je pense que sur la
crédibilité d'une certaine gauche sur ce
texte là ce serait cela ne sera pas
nécessaire et par ailleurs je pense que
sur ce texte là ce serait dommage
puisque notre quinquennat s'inscrit dans
une logique de promotion du dialogue
social c'est une erreur politique ça
serait en fait une erreur politique la
démocratie sociale c'est un des éléments
phares des engagements et je crois des
réalisations du président hollande
arrivé sur un texte qui organise de
nouveau le rêve le dialogue social en
france et est
démocratie sociale à un passage en force
serait une erreur politique dans ce
texte il y avait aussi 18 cv anonyme qui
avait été mis en place par par la droite
il a été annulé pour star recul d'avancé
alors je sais que les dernières
évaluations de ce cv anonyme ne sont pas
très concluante candidats la réduction
des discriminations il se trouve que par
ailleurs le parti socialiste souhaite
que le cv anonyme soit adapté donc
continuons à discuter
la raison pour laquelle le cv anonyme a
été retirée du texte
voilà ne figure plus c'est que les
dernières évaluations sont
malheureusement pas très concluante vous
avez une nouvelle négociation une
nouvelle ouverture de ce que je souhaite
c'est que dans leur esprit que ça dans
notre pays quel que soit son prénom et
quelle que soit sa couleur de peau ne
soit pas traité différemment al embauche
et toute solution qui permettra ça donc
on aura une autre question sur
l'ensemble de cette discussion 700
amendements pour pour ce seul texte
c'est beaucoup est ce que pour vous il
est encore possible de débattre
correctement en séance publique avec
autant d'un moment vous qui préconisait
quand même la simplification c'est assez
difficile je suis une dingue et où une
jeune députée je n'ai que 3 ans
d'expérience je suis parfois ses 700
amendements sagesse hubertine je suis
parfois gênés notamment en loi de
finances par le
l'extrême complexité voire parfois
l'extrême
comment dire le côté un tout petit peu
non législatif de certains amendements
alors je suis totalement favorable au
débat parlementaire mais on arrive à un
moment où il ya de plus en plus
d'amendements qui deviennent politique
ou qui deviennent tout simplement on va
dire technique et ne relève pas de la
loi comme pas ou quand le premier
ministre introduit des abonnements sur
le compte de pénibilité par exemple dans
un texte sur le dialogue social qui sont
en procès c'est une démarche politique
politiques utilisent non non non non non
pas du tout politique au sens du goût
c'est la volonté de traduire un dialogue
social un accord social dans la loi
après c'est véritablement pour le coup
l'utilisation de la loi dans un contexte
politique détriment du travail
parlementaire dit disons avec la
difficulté de savoir comment les
parlementaires peuvent revenir à la
qualité du texte à la pureté de la loi
je sais des sujets par exemple que
claude bartolone explore depuis de
nombreuses semaines dans son groupe
institutions auxquelles j'appartiens et
pour l'instant je suis modeste et je
vous avoue que je ne comprends pas dit
donc faux pas de solution si vous ne
comprenez pas encore ce jour bas ça
viendra peut-être devait repartir au
sénat cette fois mardi la réforme du
droit d'asile a été adoptée après son
passage en commission des lois et en
séance la majorité de droite a durci le
projet gouvernemental avec une priorité
obliger les des goûters du droit d'asile
à quitter le territoire français
et de son côté l'assemblée nationale a
donné son feu vert à la transition
énergétique pour un nouveau vote il
prévoit notamment la réduction d'un
tiers du parc nucléaire et veut faire de
la france un exemple dans ce domaine
approche de la conférence de paris sur
le climat c'est un projet de loi porté
par ségolène royal qui s'est félicité à
plusieurs reprises justement de sa
méthode de travail avec les
parlementaires elle dit que c'est une
réussite vous croyez aussi bien le
niveau n'est que dans
ma part je crois que c'est le texte le
mieux adopté en première lecture en tout
cas à l'assemblée nationale donc voila
quand on a le dialogue quand on a la
construction par voie d'amendement
débattue et est entendu on obtient un
vote très majoritaire ultra majeur
je constate simplement que la ministre a
non seulement abouti à ces objectifs
c'est à dire finir ensemble des
solutions à moyen terme pour préserver
l'environnement et en même temps
politiquement elle a rassemblé une
grande majorité elle a dit ça m'enrage
réconcilier les écologistes peut-être
cpc qui a fait c'est qu'il est
effectivement pas le moindre de ses
qualités du texte à vous parler peu
utile tout à l'heure on va y venir va
pas quelques mots de l'ump si vous
voulez bien qui va devenir les
républicains ça ne vous a pas échappé la
justice en tout cas l'a autorisée vous
avez peut-être entendu nicolas sarkozy
aussi s'exprimer à propos du président
de la république qui lui a même trouvé
un surnom écouter mais un truc que
j'avais pas prévu
c'est que moi je voulais choisir lui
même le nom de notre formation politique
les gens qui n'ont pas de colonne
vertébrale il essaye de gagner sur le
tapis vert il essaye d'aller devant les
tribunaux pour obtenir devant les
tribunaux ce qui ne peuvent plus obtenir
devant le peuple de france voilà ce qui
s'est passé avec le parti socialiste
on va venir sur ce nom des républicains
simplement moi je ça vous fait rire on
ne fait absolument paris on parle quand
même la personne qui vient de s'exprimer
à présider la république française
pendant cinq ans et en est trois ans
plus tard à insulter toute la justice
française a insulté personnellement au
président de la république ce n'est pas
son bord politique m'enfin quand même
bref a insulté l'un les institutions
françaises n'allez pas choisi de
chercher trop loin la montée du vote
populiste quand un ancien président de
la république s'est pas dit l'ancien
président était pas d baissé surtout à
les mixer badine c'est lui qui voit
c'est surtout que ça provoque en rejet
de l'ensemble des institutions et donc
de la représentation démocratique
représentatif française mardi et le vote
populiste découle directement de ce type
de propos donc voilà nicolas sarkozy est
égal à lui-même ce n'est pas très
étonnant ce qui est très ennuyeux c'est
qu'ils ne se rendent pas compte à quel
point il abîme la république en essence
et sur les républicains vous en pensez
quoi est ce que c'est capturer une
certaine forme de politique et capturer
un petit peu les français autour de ce
nom je pense que la la l'utilisation de
ce terme
témoigne du fait que la droite a basculé
dans une sorte de politique de
communication où il n'y a plus que les
mots qui sont utilisés et très peu les
idées il faut simplement se dire que la
personne qui propose d'appeler son parti
des républicains est mise en jeu d'hier
est mise en cause dans de nombreuses
procédures possibles police judiciaire
actuellement et au fond est en train de
jouer sur une forme de double langage
d'un côté on appelle à la république via
la dénomination de son parti et de
l'autre on critique les institutions et
surtout on critique la justice parce que
la justice nous met en cause ce double
langage là est très gênante pour ça
qu'il joue avec les valeurs de la
république vous diriez ça je suis pas
s'ils jouent en tout cas d'un côté on
utilise les mots de la république en se
les approprient et de l'autre on tape
sur les institutions la représentation
républicaine on voit bien l'incohérence
de la chose et on voit bien aussi que
c'est lié au fait que monsieur sarkozy
et mis en cause dans de nombreuses
procédures sur vous autant quelque part
nicolas sarkozy n'aurait plus sa place
c'est ça j'ai pas dis ça je dis
simplement que les propos qu'il a ne
sont pas digne de quelqu'un qui prétend
représenter de nouveau la république
française est-ce que vous pensez que la
campagne de 2017 est déjà lancée à
distance avec françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy qui dans des registres
différents se disputent les valeurs de
la république si je puis dire si la
campagne de 2017 est lancé c'est bien du
fait de nicolas sarkozy qui lui même est
en train
d'organiser l'ensemble des du combat
politique au travers de prises de
paroles qui sont des paroles des prises
de paroles vraiment politiciens on va
prendre un peu de hauteur en ouvrant une
page d'histoire avec mercredi l'hommage
de la nation aux résistants
deux femmes deux hommes quatre figures
de la résistance entrée au panthéon
geneviève de gaulle antonio saint
germaine tillon pierre brossolette et
jean zay françois hollande aura rendu un
hommage solennel petit extrait avec
jérôme rabier
le chef de l'état avait longuement
préparé cette cérémonie depuis sa prise
de fonction en 2012 il souhaitait en
faire un moment fort de sa présidence
lorsqu'il s'élance dans la rue qui mène
au panthéon il est suivi de quatre
portraits de quatre cercueils de quatre
personnalités qu'il a souhaité faire
entrer dans ce temple de l'histoire
française ils sont accompagnés dans
cette marche par des jeunes habillés aux
couleurs de la république cette
république pour laquelle ils ont lutté
et que le chef de l'état a de nombreuses
fois invoqué dans son hommage solennel
sont quatre
deux hommes deux femmes
quatre destins
quatre chemins
quatre histoires
qui donnent chair et visage à la
république en en rappelant les valeurs
et à travers eux c'est l'actualité
récente qui l'a traité car pour françois
hollande c'est la république et a été
attaqué début janvier à paris et ces
quatre personnalités ont chacun à leur
manière défendu l'esprit de résistance
il n'hésite pas à prendre changé en
exemple pour parler de l'école
républicaine
c'est par l'école que la république
reste fidèle à sa promesse
c'est par l'excellence qu'elles élèvent
le plus grand nombre et qu'elle renforce
le rayonnement du pays c'est par la
laïcité qu'elle dresse un mur
infranchissable
devant ceux qui veulent diviser les
français et c'est par l'intégration
qu'elle fait aimer la france puis c'est
pierre brossolette et sa vision
avant-gardiste de la république qui est
cité par françois hollande ils voulaient
une république moderne une république
ouverte une république généreuse une
république exigeante la tâche n'est
toujours pas fini nous devons la mener
jusqu'au bout
longuement applaudi le chef de l'état a
ensuite accompagné l'entrée dans le
panthéon de ces quatre cercueils chargé
d'histoire aux côtés des familles il
s'est recueilli dans leur dernière
demeure ce panthéon qui plus que jamais
symbolise la reconnaissance de la patrie
à ces grands hommes et femmes
alors vous avez écouté ce discours est
ce que vous pensez qu'il restera dans
les annales du quinquennat au même titre
que celui du 11 janvier je pense que
c'était un très grand discours un très
beau discours et qui pose la question de
notre rapport au temps les entrées au
panthéon sont l'occasion de discours
politique qui marque les juifs célèbrent
évidemment c'est celui portant sur
l'entrée de jean moulin par andré
malraux mais on est sur quelque chose
qui est le témoin de la difficulté de
notre société politique actuelle
l'instantanéité il y à 3000 qui n'a ni
la parole qui annihile le message
politique là c'est l'histoire c'est la
nation française c'est la résistance
c'est ce qui au fond fait notre
république et font de notre nation c'est
un grand discours comment faire pour que
ce moment-là échappe à l'instantanéité
politique et et s'inscrit dans la
question puisque dès l'aube a quasiment
plus parler d'eux c'est bien pour ça que
je vous remercie de vous en parler
aujourd'hui est de revenir sur ce moment
là et c'est à nous élus de
replacer certains éléments politiques
dans le temps mais ce que vous croyez
justement que dans 20 30 50 ou 60 ans ce
type d'hommage d'une nation qui honorent
sa mémoire c'est mort sera encore là est
ce que ces valeurs sont menacés pour
vous je pense que c'est très menacé tout
simplement parce que le rapport à
l'histoire disparaît petit à petit de
notre vie quotidienne politique il y à
la nécessité de rappeler ce qu'est le
patrimoine au sens large du terme on
n'est pas dans la consommation immédiate
pour faire une nation pour faire une
république on doit s'inscrire dans dans
une histoire et s'inscrire dans une
histoire ça passe pas prendre le temps
des coups de s'écouter à certains
moments de la vie politique mais les
mémoires et politique comme l'a fait
françois hollande on a bien compris en
filigrane dans son discours qui ne parle
évidemment de tout ce qui se passait
depuis
le début de son quinquennat jusque là où
il voulait en venir en 2017 c'est bien
ça donc c'est naturel de s'inscrire au
sida de te dire de projeter le message
de l'histoire et de la mémoire
républicaine dans un dans un continuum
et du monde mélange des genres peut-être
ponot et je crois comme ans et voilà
comment fait-on désormais en france pour
ne pas passer entre le du jour au
lendemain voire du matin à l'après-midi
d'un sujet à l'autre d'un moment
politique et comment sait-on justement
on prend le temps de discuter avec vous
et je vous ferez de votre émission on
fait en sorte que quand on est élu on
place un peu ce genre de choses c'est
vrai que voilà il faut qu'on perde un
peu l'habitude de réagir à tous et à
tous les sujets à tous et est forte
quand même je reviens de deux secondes
son image pour se lancer dans le
discours de la candidate ah non vraiment
là pour le coup je ne suis pas d'accord
avec les lectures qui en a été fait
parce que c'était un discours qui est
justement essayer de simplement de se
dire qu'on est dans un quinquennat de la
vème république qui doit aussi
s'inscrire dans le passé et projeter
l'avenir mais sans qu'il y ait deux
dimensions politicienne d'un est présent
on va revenir à l'actualité politique
puisque je dis on parle de votre parti
et du choix et militant social
alors les militants socialistes se sont
prononcés la motion a porté par jean
christophe cambadélis a obtenu plus de
70% leur est un peu à l'apaisement les
frondeurs donne moins de la voix et
pourtant et pourtant récit de jean
baptiste daoulas
les militants du ps ont tranché les
frondeurs pèse moins de 30% dans le
parti alors à l'assemblée les députés
légitimiste espère que la fronde va
s'éteindre rapidement
il ya une légitimité qui a été qui s'est
clairement exprimée donc il faut que
tout le monde en tienne compte j'ai
entendu les déclarations d'un certain
nombre de mes collègues disant que le
temps de la fronde et est maintenant
passé tant mieux le temps de la
discussion il sera toujours présent mais
si l'on peut discuter sans fronde et je
crois que ça nous donnera de la force
mais les frondeurs ont une autre lecture
du vote des militants d'après eux les
socialistes ont majoritairement demandé
d inflexion de la politique économique
pas question donc de rentrer dans le
rang il ya potentiellement une majorité
d'idées si vous regardez les choses pour
que ces inflexions soit votée dans les
instances du parti socialiste et nos
positions nos combats au parlement
procéderont peut-être davantage
maintenant que les militants ont se sont
prononcés et ont organisé un équilibre
au sein des motions nos positions
parlement procéderont davantage des
débats qui auront lieu au sein de notre
formation difficile de savoir si la
majorité sera plus disciplinés après le
congrès du ps dans le doute françois
rebsamen a déclaré ce week-end qu'il
n'hésiterait pas à utiliser l'article
49-3 sur le projet de loi sur le
dialogue social je ne souhaite pas qu'il
y ait de 49,3 au contraire tout le
travail que j'ai fait en amont avec les
partenaires sociaux mais aussi avec les
parlementaires et y compris même avec
les socialistes ce bureau nationale
m'incite à penser que n'aura pas besoin
du 49-3 pas de 49,3 donc à moins que
certains députés nos tentes de
détricoter le texte ou menacent de ne
pas le soutenir au moment du vote
solennel
alors je vous présente gerra fait d'une
autre partenaire american figaro nous
allons
vous
vous interrogez vous allez passer sous
la loupe du scan en quelques secondes
mais d'abord je te vous interroger sur
une partition victoire de jean
christophe cambadélis a pas 70% au
premier secrétaire victoire de jean
christophe cambadélis ou françois
hollande alors c'est jean christophe
cambadélis qui est en tant que premier
signataire de la motion a à la fois
emporté la ligne 10 c'est important dans
votre reportage il a été mentionné le
fait que c'était la fin de la fronde
parlementaire j'ai souscrit mais c'est
aussi la fin d'un éventuel le tient
d'une éventuelle aventure sociale
libérale au sein du parti socialiste
ah oui jean christophe quand même ça a
été au moins clair dans sa motion sur
quelques points qui ait pas de fraudes
mais pas de social libéralisme
les hawks et les deux aventures à la
fois et de temps pas steve des 2
tentation pardon excusez moi qui
s'arrête avec ce vote des militants
c'est pour ça que la majorité sénateurs
de votre motion celle que vous portiez
s'est rallié à la motion majoritaire
c'est parce que vous obtenez des
assurances d'une inflexion notre courant
n'a obtenu aucune aucun aucun engagement
ni aucune ni aucun n'y a aucune
discussion à ce choix le suédois était
liée au fait que quand vous avez 60 %
des militants qui choisissent une motion
il est logique politiquement de faire en
sorte que le premier signataire applique
cette ligne politique nous n'aurions
peut-être pas été dans la même situation
si la motion n'avait pas fait 60% il est
clair qu'avec 60 % pour nous il allait
de soi et je crois que le vote de 70%
témoin du fait qu'on avait la bonne
lecture il va de soi pour les militants
qu'une fois qu'on a décidé à une
politique on laisse celui qui l'a mené
bien j'ai partie par jean christophe
cambadélis qui réalise un peu son rêve
de toujours en plus il a doublé
maintenant par les adhérents ça y est
c'est fait il est légitime il est
doublement légitime il est légitime sur
la ligne politique est légitime sur en
tant que premier secrétaire
du fait du vote vous attendez quoi
maintenant de ce premier secrétaire
alors légitime beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses il a du pain sur la
planche notre premier secrétaire
première chose c'est rassembler il faut
qu'au congrès de poitiers quand on sort
du congrès de poitiers qui a lieu début
juin tous les partis socialistes soient
rassemblés de la droite du parti à la
gauche du parti il ne doit manquer aucun
socialiste à la paix la fin du congrès
de poitiers pour la bataille de 2017
fondeur compris frondeurs compris et
frondeur sur rien compris deuxième sujet
pour jacques et savent comment ils se
renouvellent partie c'était notre
message et ça sera continuera d'être
notre message au nouveau leur profonde
elle partie renouvelée déjà profondément
le parti renouveler la façon de
s'exprimer et renouveler la ushl milite
renouveler la façon de se structurer
bref est à la franc à l'image de la
france de 2015 c'était notre message de
motions des notions la fabrique c'est
celui que nous continuerons à porter
avec nous tout notre petit score de 10%
mais là vous avez être là pour veiller
justement surtout ça vu que vous ne
voulez pas siéger au conseil national et
je siège au conseil national bureau
national non je ne participerai pas au
secrétaire national parce que je pense
que le message que nous avons portée
politique à l'intérieur du parti qui est
bien les nouvelles générations qui à 20
ans qui a trente ans qu'il ya 40 ans qui
veut secouer ce parti et le rendre
beaucoup plus attractif est beaucoup
plus moderne ce message là c'est nous
qui l'avons porté dans le dos que je
serai la vigie tepa alliés en tout cas
le porte parole alors justement je
voudrais que je vous interroger sur jean
christophe cambadélis et ses premières
déclarations en tant que nouveaux
premiers secrétaires élus il prévoit
toujours l'idée d'une possibilité d'une
primaire pour l'élection présidentielle
de 2017 quelque chose c'est dans les
statuts de notre parti soyons clair dans
les statuts de notre parti n'est il
qu'une seule solution normalement pour
des un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle soutenue par le parti
socialiste c'est le mécanisme des
primaires il n'existe pas d'autres
chapitres d'autres paragraphe qui
prévoit autre chose donc jean christophe
cambadélis ne souhaite pas je crois
comprendre les primaires en tout cas moi
je souhaite que quel que soit le
mécanisme ce soit françois hollande qui
soit notre candidat en 2017 en revanche
et comment on fait pour rassembler au
maximum c'est le candidat naturel je
propose moi c'est plus que le condamné
naturel c'est quoi le candidat qui ne
devra être notre candidat absolument le
candidat naturel légitime qui devront y
meurt quand on a dream primaire ou pas
alors nous avons plaidé plutôt pour une
primaire pour rassembler les socialistes
et la gauche autour de françois hollande
au premier tour nous avons co 10 % donc
ce n'est pas notre voie que y'aura qui
sera appliqué à jean christophe
cambadélis de nous expliquer comment ils
voient le rassemblement du parti et de
la gauche autour de françois hollande
était apparu primaire faut changer les
statuts je me suis un peu ennuyé par le
fait que nos statuts effectivement ne
prévoit pas de plan b ah oui qu'est ce
que vous pensez de son idée d'alliance
populaire avec les partis de gauche et
des citoyens qu est ce que la sueur bien
sûr la ruine comment qui colle oui alors
ces domaines c'est plutôt lui il faut
poser la question mais vous souhaitez
fois d'abord que la ligne politique soit
clair c'est une socialiste n'est pas une
from dust lane social libéral je pense
que déjà une fois qu'on aura bien
proposer ça le sera plus simple d'aller
discuter avec nos partenaires verts ou
aux partenaires prg et puis
effectivement c'est la capacité que nous
avons à nous à nous à nous changer le
même aussi on ne peut pas rester sur la
façon de faire la politique commencée il
ya 10 ou 15 ans nos partenaires de
gauche ne s'y retrouvent pas à nous de
nous réinventer bien compris elle fait
partie jim géré assez hélas hélas look
jusqu
alors dit on va reparler de christophe
cambadélis a un tout petit peu encore un
tout petit peu eux vous avez donc
soutenir la ligne majoritaire de jean
christophe cambadélis après le vote des
motions ce premier secrétaire de
légitimes vous nous dites aujourd'hui
pendant la campagne d'émotions vous
n'avez pas toujours été très tendre avec
lui on écoute un petit extrait
jean christophe cambadélis commence
toute sa campagne par bien non il est
devenu monsieur non dans cette campagne
interne alors vous juriez également que
vous n'aviez pas vocation à choisir
entre jean christophe cambadélis tel
christian paul un train entre deux
cravates voilà je ne choisis pas entre
deux cravates avez vous dit force est de
constater que qu'avant justement le vote
sur les premiers secrétaires vous avez
fait votre choix un acte d'allégeance
qui n'est pas très brillant dit votre
camarade de motion paul quilès est-ce
que vous lui répondez je ne réponds
appel qu il s en priver la différence à
la différence de lui via via la presse
on n'a pas choisi entre de cravate on a
choisi une ligne politique on a acté et
c'est collectif c'est l'ensemble de des
représentants sera pas les mandataires à
l'internaute partie de notre motion qui
ont dit voilà 60 % c'est une majorité il
n'est pas possible d'envisager que ce
soit une autre direction minoritaire qui
prennent la tête du parti alors que 60 %
des mises en ce sens exprimé donc nous
n'avons pas choisi entre de travail nous
avons bel et bien choisi une majorité
politique voulue par les militants
est-ce qu'il faut voir dans ce
ralliement une envie pour vous de vous
rapprocher un peu plus de la ligue
gouvernementale on vous décrit souvent
comme très bosseuse très ambitieuse
aussi est ce qu'un poste au gouvernement
ça pourrait vous intéresser
rien à voir pas vraiment je vous espère
que la wii le congrès le congrès ps n'a
rien à voir avec la question
gouvernementale le congrès ps c'est de
savoir si les militants socialistes sont
d'accord avec un soutien au gouvernement
claire est la réponse est oui et ça a
été notre credo à nous pendant toute la
campagne intégral il ya neuf députés à
la fabrick 9 députés ce qui est pas
petit d'ailleurs à neuf la faverie pour
une petite motion il n'y a pas de fronde
heures chez nous donc on a toujours été
très clair on voulait justement que le
parti décide une bonne fois pour toutes
si la question de la fraude était
terminée ou pas la question de la fronde
est terminée cela signifie quelque chose
de très concret pour nous c'est qu'au
bureau national il n'y aura pas de
majorité alternative à jean christophe
cambadélis contrairement à ce que
christian paul ou laurent baumel le
suggérez vous ne répondez pas à la
question est ce que vous pensez qu'un
gouvernement doit mieux représentant les
représenter les multiples tendances du
parti socialiste telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui à commencer par votre
tendance non je crois pas que le
gouvernement doit rester dans une
position qui est la sienne qui est clair
qui est celle de manuel valls et qui
désormais est la majorité du parti
socialiste c'est dommage parce que vous
avez le cd parfait de la ministrable
mais si vous avez oublié ministre à jean
il aurait
vous avez une formation d'économiste
vous avez déjà travaillé à bercy vous
êtes aussi aux fonctionnaires puisque
vous a été diplômé de polytechnique
notamment à ce propos j'ai une petite
question à vous poser est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec la proposition de
bruno le maire qui propose d'obliger les
politiques hauts fonctionnaires de
démissionner de la haute fonction
publique est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne proposition je ne crois
pas parce que je pense que pour le coup
on est sûr
on va dire une obsession de la droite
est parti en gros le maire depuis qu'il
est en train de dériver lentement vers
la droite de son parti c'est quelque
chose anti-fonctionnaires voilà on est
anti fonctionnaires ce que je voudrais
moi c'est que les gens qui sont dans le
privé qui travaillent dans le privé il
se trouve que je travaille dans le privé
avant d'être élus ne soient pas obligés
eux de tout abandonner de tout perdre
tout arrêté au moment où ils sont élus
ça c'est la vraie question la question
n'est pas de savoir s'il faut taper
absolument sur le statut des
fonctionnaires comme la droite de plus
en plus extrêmes veut le faire et bruno
le maire en est désormais un héros
plaire aux ulis mais pour ce
que j'en ai entendu c'est bon les
solutions de bruno le maire pourquoi
quelqu'un qui travaille dans le privé et
qui est élu n'ait pas où elle ne soit
pas obligé de démissionner ça ça
m'intéresserait beaucoup plus derrière
les bons dernière petite question
d'actualité eric woerth a été blanchi
hier dans le procès bettencourt après
cinq années de procédures dans une
interview au figaro ce matin il réclame
des excuses de la part d'un certain
nombre de responsables socialistes à
commencer par martine aubry jean marc
ayrault ou claude bartolone est ce que
vous pensez que le ps doit voilà
reconnaître peut-être allé trop loin
dans sa dans sa dénonciation jeu eric
woerth mettant mettre sur la table les
termes qui ont été utilisés ou pas on a
un problème d'exemplarité en france du
monde politique à gauche nous avons fait
en sorte de faire démissionner tout ce
qui était mis en examen ou qui étaient
mis en cause avant même d'être condamné
le cas le plus ennuyeux pour nous et qui
continue à me faire monde c'est le cas
de monsieur cahuzac
le sujet il n'est pas de savoir si on ne
s'excuse pas le sujet c'est comment on
fait pour que l'exemplarité soit la
règle systématique dans notre monde
politique de manière à ce que les
français reprennent confiance dans la
représentation politique c'est un sujet
avec elle à ce stade la pression des
notions la présomption d'innocence
d'eric woerth n'a selon vous pas été
bafouée par le parti socialiste à
l'époque je sais qu'il ya eu des prises
aux questions assez dur même benoît
hamon ce matin le dit
dans une sorte de mea coupable voilà il
apporte du ps à l'époque peut-être qu'on
est allé un peu loin il faut aussi
avoir un peu de tenue dans le débat
politique je ne crois pas que ce soit
vrai le problème principal problème
principal c'est comment on fait pour que
pendant des mois et des années il n'est
pas des soupçons sur certaines personnes
qui sont élus et cela passe je crois par
des mesures dynegy bibi d'inéligibilité
avis possible de la part de la justice
sur un certain nombre de cas merci merci
à vous merci jean pour cette analyse
c'est tout du sud du scanner on poursuit
avec ce dossier amazon c'est notre plus
de l'hebdo
amazon paiera désormais ses impôts en
europe la commission européenne a gagné
une première bataille contre le géant de
vente en ligne mais la partie des sans
doute pas fini explications de simon
barbarie
les arrangements fiscaux des
multinationales en europe est bientôt
fini en tout cas cette semaine c'est
amazon qui annonce vouloir rentrer dans
le rang désormais la firme paiera ses
impôts pays par pays fini donc les
textes ruling ces accords secrets qui
ont permis à amazon de bénéficier de la
fiscalité très arrangeante du luxembourg
avec pour conséquence des millions
d'euros de perdus pour les états membres
là où la multinationale réalisait
vraiment ses bénéfices alors ce mea
culpa d'amazon est il intéressé ou une
manière d'amadouer la commission
européenne nous continuerons lankaise
octobre 2014 en prenant en compte l'
annonce d'amazones concernant le
changement de ces dispositions fiscales
il y a quelques mois le scandale du luxe
l'x avait mis en lumière de forts
soupçons d'évasion fiscale pratiquée par
des multinationales comme apple ikea ou
encore mcdonald's des montages
financiers complexes rendue possible par
l'absence d'harmonisation fiscale comme
l'a esquissé l'économiste thomas piketty
cette semaine sur france inter à la
solution au lieu de simplement se
plaindre et de déplorer comme le fond
les gouvernements français ou allemand
c'est de se mettre ensemble et d'avoir
un impôt commun sur les sociétés au
moins sur les plus grandes sociétés
multinationales les consommateurs ont
aussi leur rôle à jouer car si amazon
fait mine de capituler en europe elle
peut aussi en tirer profit se
débarrasser de son image de fraudeurs et
ainsi éviter le boycott de ses clients
karine berger vous connaissez bien ses
dossiers ce que pour vous ces promesses
de transparence de repentance fiscale si
je puis dire cache quelque chose est ce
que vous pensez que
est ce que vous croyez à cette mise au
pas d'amazon je ne crois pas un instant
mais le sujet il est politique cela fait
dix ans que la france a voté non au
traité constitutionnel européen parce
que les citoyens français ne croyait
plus à la capacité de l'europe de lutter
contre explique mme en lettres j'ai
petit nom il ya dix
assurent un traité constitutionnel
européen tel que celui qui était proposé
et qui devait d'ailleurs état d'esprit
je continue avec ses dents sur ce
dossier là mais c'est la même chose les
français les européens mais vous avez
fait quoi en disant vous avez des
grandes multinationales qui vont aux
pays bas puis après qui se transforme
irlande qui paye 0 euros d'impôts c'est
pas parce que amazon annonce qui veulent
payer quelques impôts c'est un petit peu
comme la taxe google et quelques heures
mais c'est pas ça l'europe l'europe
c'est d'imposer que des grands groupes
de ce type là qui se prennent pour qui
considèrent qu'ils sont au dessus des
lois soit soumises aux lois européennes
zone google fait donc vraiment et
européennes il est temps je veux
comprendre mais vous pensez que l'europe
a vraiment les moyens d'imposer ses
règles à ces géants là à minima sur le
problème c'est qu'il faudrait que
l'europe soit bien décidé à être
l'europe et okwari pourquoi ils ne
payent pas d'impôts c'est très simple
parce que les pays-bas propose à toute
entreprise de rassembler ses filiales
aux pays bas et à près de pouvoir
exporter les profits via l'irlande sur
des paradis fiscaux c'est la façon dont
ces dons nous donne aux pays européens
on va dire organiser la compétition
interne c'est un scandale et c'est la
démonstration s'il était nécessaire que
dix ans après le nombre était aussi un
européen mais la souveraineté européenne
n'est toujours pas une évidence en tout
cas en matière fiscale c'est sûr sur le
report au voc qui ne fait que
notre invité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine sur lcp public sénat pour une
autre émission très bonne suite de
programmes d'arrêt